يغلق النيتو باب العضويه في وجه اوكرانيا
في الوقت الراهن على الاقل لكنه يفتح
نوافذ اخرى للتعاون تقدم مجموعه السبع خطه
تشمل ضمانات امنيه لاوكرانيا اهم هذه
الضمانات انشاء صندوق غربي للمساعدات
الماليه طويله الامد اضمان امداد اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه الحديثه والمتطوره على المدى
الطويل بالاضافه الى الالتزام بتدريب
الجنود الاوكرانيين تهدف هذه الخطوات وفق
المسؤولين في النيتو الى ردع اي هجوم
مستقبلي وارسال رساله لروسيا بان الزمن
ليس في مصلحتها بمعنى اخر يقول النيتو
لروسيا ان علاقته مع اوكرانيا ستتعزز مع
مرور الوقت اما عن الطريقه التي ستنفذ
فيها هذه الخطه فستكون عبر اتفاقيات
ثنائيه بين مجموعه دول السبع واوكرانيا
على غرار العلاقه بين الولايات المتحده
واسرائيل اذ تدفع الولايات المتحده
لاسرائيل مليارات الدولارات السنويه
مساعدات امنيه وعسكريه تعتبر الولايات
المتحده المموله الاكبر ماليا في العالم
باسرائيل تبحث واشنطن عن استنساخ هذه
العلاقه الخاصه مع اسرائيل لتكون علاقات
لمجموعه السبع مع اوكرانيا اذ بلغت
التزامات الولايات المتحده اتجاه اوكرانيا
حوالي 37 مليار دولار منذ بدايه الحرب اذا
ما نفذت هذه الخطه المقترحه فستتعزز قدرات
اوكرانيا العسكريه دون التزام الناتو بخوض
صراع مباشر مع روسيا ابرز مبادئ الناتو
تعتبر ان اي اعتداء على اي عضو هو اعتداء
على جميع الاعضاء بهذا يشكل الناتو مظله
لجميع البلدان الراغبه في تزويد اوكرانيا
بالمساعدات العسكريه المستمره حتى لو كانت
التفاصيل تختلف من بلد الى اخر ترحب
اوكرانيا لكنها تطالب بالمزيد امر اثار
استياء اكثر من مره في واشنطن التي بتقديم
كييف بعض الامتنان اما في لندن فيقول وزير
الدفاع بوضوح اظهروا بعض الامتنان نحن
لسنا امازون المزيد في نظر زيلينسكي هو
اسلحه بعيده المدى تعاهدت فرنسا بتقديم
بعض منها بعد التحفظ للغرب على تقديمها
حتى لا تضرب الاراضي الروسيه بها عليه
تتورط تلك الدول في الصراع بشكل مباشر رغم
كل هذه الحفاوه باوكرانيا في قمه النيتو
الا ان الاوكرانيين متحفظون على عدم وجود
جدول زمني لتنفيذ خطه الضمانات تلك هذا
امر عبثي غير مسبوق يقول زيلينسكي هكذا
يدخل العالم في طور اعاده تشكيل العلاقات
والتحالفات بعد عام ونصف من حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]